[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle à 360 voici les titres
le parti socialiste peut-il survivre l
élection d' emmanuel macron manuel valls
entend rejoindre la majorité
présidentielle aux législatives
impossible de conserver sa carte au ps
tout en revendiquant l'étiquette en
marche lui répond jean christophe
cambadélis vous l'entendrez dans un
instant la droite s'interroge aussi sur
la stratégie adoptée après la victoire
d'emmanuel macron si l'objectif affiché
est imposé un gouvernement de
cohabitation
le parti a l'air redoutent des
désertions le bureau politique est
réunie nous serons en direct dans cette
édition
réunion au sommet aussi au fn après une
matinée consacrée aux législatives
un conseil stratégique se tient au qg de
campagne afin de tirer les conséquences
du mauvais score jugé décevant de marine
le pen alors que le parti frontiste veut
être la première force d'opposition
le débat est à suivre et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur twitter hashtag
présidentielle à 360 pour m'accompagner
ce soir sa verrière ogec et m tran huy
le multiplex s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est donc manuel valls qui le premier a
lancé les hostilités ce matin avant même
le début du bureau national ancien
premier ministre a affirmé qu'il serait
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
aux législatives pour lui le ps est mort
une annonce accueillie fraîchement du
côté dans marche flora sauvage à peine
deux jours après la victoire de son ex
rival manuel valls annonce sa
candidature aux législatives sous
l'étiquette la république en marche
le nouveau parti des manuels macro je
veux la réussite et les manuels
m'attends donc comme j'invite d'ailleurs
tous les députés sortants l'ailé les
progressistes ce qu'ils ont appelé à
voter pour emmanuel macron avant le
premier tour ce qu'ils souhaitaient sa
victoire moi je serai candidat de la
majorité présidentielle
je souhaite m'inscrire dans ce mouvement
qui est le sien la république en marche
la nouvelle est accueillie fraîchement
dans le camp macro et tous le répète son
investiture ne sera pas automatique
ces choses soient claires la parole d'un
ancien premier ministre à paroles d'un
ancien ministre
la parole d'un parlementaire sortant est
évidemment différente mais la règle
reste la même pour tous la procédure a
été établie et elle sera respectée c'est
une commission nationale d'investiture
qui est souveraine et indépendante qui
examinera les candidatures qui seront
déposés tout candidat investi sous la
république en marche qui est la bannière
de nos candidats devra être passé par
l'examen de la commission d'investiture
et cette commission d'investiture a déjà
arrêté son choix sur une candidate dans
la première circonscription de l'essonne
que vise manuel valls autre obstacle
pour l'ex premier ministre le parti
socialiste l'a prévenu il devra choisir
entre l'étiquette socialiste sous
l'étiquette la république en marche
si certains veulent partir ou se
singulariser qu'ils le fassent et nous
laisse travailler en se présentant sous
l'étiquette la république en marche
manuel valls part du principe que le
président élu aura du mal à disposer
d'une majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale en le rejoignant dés à présent
ils espèrent peser sur un échiquier
politique en pleine recomposition et le
cas valls ils sont les tensions qui
traversent le ps en ce moment faut-il
être dans oi côté de la majorité
présidentielle la question divise
les sénateurs socialistes ils étaient
réunis ce matin pour tirer les
conséquences de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron 120 cerqueira manuel valls prêt à
rejoindre emmanuel macron chez les
sénateurs socialistes personne n'est
surpris mais tous le savent derrière son
cas c'est bien la ligne du ps qui se
joue pour didier guillaume aucun doute
le ps est bien mort il faut soutenir
emmanuel macron nous sommes dans la
majorité présidentielle parce que nous
avons voté pour emmanuel macron nous
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite et
pour soutenir son projet il n'y a pas de
conditions à mettre pour le soutenir
pour qu'il réussisse faire partie de la
nouvelle majorité
la quasi totalité du groupe socialiste
au sénat est d'accord ils sont nombreux
comme jean pierre sueur à vouloir que le
ps survivent dans en marche et réclame
la double appartenance à un parti comme
c'est le cas pour le modem je crois que
la majorité futur toit doit comprendre
tous ceux qui sont pour une gauche de
gouvernement dont nous sommes plus en
marche plus des centristes qui sont pour
la réforme et pour le progrès et donc
qui se sont détachés de l air et
monsieur fillon c'est clair sauf que du
côté des soutiens des manuels macron on
estime que c'est un peu trop facile il
faut choisir
l'objectif n'est pas d'ouvrir la porte à
de futures frondeurs bernard cazeau
compte bien quitter le ps pour
s'investir pleinement dans en marche
selon lui une coalition n'est
envisageable que si emmanuel macron
n'obtient pas de majorité absolue
ensuite eh bien certains pourront tout à
fait rejoindre la majorité
présidentielle et soutenir la démarche
du manuel macro tout en restant dans un
parti qu'ils soient républicains
centristes ou rld être dans la majorité
dans l'opposition ou conserver l'unité
de la maison socialiste en aidant le
nouveau président en fonction d'un texte
de loi
les socialistes se cherchent une
stratégie ce qui est sûr c'est que le ps
va devoir finir par trancher et on va
tout de suite retrouvé ta mme tran huy
devant la maison
la mutualité tam on sait que jean
christophe cambadélis doit s'exprimer
c'est un bureau national qui s'annonce
sous tension
oui effectivement car cela devait être
aujourd'hui une journée de rassemblement
un consacré à la plateforme du parti
socialiste pour les législatives
en clair sur la ligne politique le
projet l'occasion de parler enfin pour
les membres du parti socialiste de ce
qui les rassemble et non pas de ceux qui
les a fracturé et peine perdue
effectivement après l'attitude de manuel
valls ce matin qui a dit à vouloir
rejoindre les rangs de la république en
marche
ici bien les cadres du parti socialiste
estime que l'ancien premier ministre a
décidément bien choisi son moment et du
coup est effectivement tous ont été
avant tout questionner sur l'attitude de
l'ancien premier ministre
on va tout de suite écoutez mathieu
hanotin ancien directeur de campagne de
benoît hamon il estime que la
déclaration de manuel valls est là pour
faire imploser le parti socialiste en
l'écoutant
d'autres disent que le parti socialiste
est mort quelle est votre réaction
oui bah vous ça vous connaissez les
pompiers pyromanes voilà donc moi j'ai
jeu je le trouve pas ça très respectueux
pour tous les militants de gauche
sincère engagé qu'il faille refonder le
parti socialiste à l'évidence
voilà mais je trouve ça un petit peu
comment dire ironique dans le mauvais
sens du terme que soit ce qui est fait
le plus de mal au parti socialiste et
provoqué la situation dans laquelle on
est arrivé aujourd'hui qui décrète que
le parti ça vaut plus rien alors que le
parti sioniste leur a tout donné depuis
des années
on comprend très bien cette colère du
côté d'un lieutenant de benoît hamon
mais on ne retrouve également la même
déception chez certains très proche de
manuel valls a notamment luc carvounas 1
le sénateur maire d'alfortville qui est
investi pour les législatives dans le
val de marne et qui lui aussi déplore
très clairement l'attitude de manuel
valls il l'a dit ce matin il ne le suis
pas du tout dans son attitude lui estime
qu'il faut qu'il y ait dans chaque
circonscription
un candidat socialiste un candidat de la
république en marche lui sera socialiste
et il se déclare prêt pour le combat en
l'écoutant on va à la fois leur aurait
sauvé résultats du parti socialiste et
son candidat et pour autant apple a
écoulé pas mort bon voilà je vous laisse
je vais retourner mais aussi à
l'intérieur
non mais vraiment comment convaincre mes
tatouages et la présidentielle parce
qu'il ya des femmes et des hommes dans
les territoires j'en fais partie je suis
candidat sur la commune la formule
cris sur scène
revoir en marche pour voir s'ils ont un
meilleur souverain que moi qui suis le
maire de cette commune colère donc très
clair du côté de luc carvounas qui n'a
donc pas caché sa déception à par
rapport à son ancien mentor pour trouver
finalement un petit peu d'apaisement
il faut aller du côté de bernard
cazeneuve re l'actuel premier ministre
l'essentiel c'est la réussite du livre
d'art c'est le rassemblement
de notre famille pour
ça compte
c'est la nécessité de moderniser et pour
cela il
fassions tous ensemble vous l'avez
entendu un bernard cazeneuve souhaite la
réussite de ce quinquennat preuve que le
parti socialiste n'a pas encore choisi
son attitude opposition ou alors encore
soutient un critique on ne sait pas mais
ce qui est très clair c'est que ça sera
du cas par cas
merci beaucoup temps mais on vous
retrouvera tout au long de cette édition
alors la droite est aussi en proie au
doute la tentation macron sème la
zizanie dans le camp et l'ère des
personnalités de droite parmi lesquels
le juppéiste edouard philippe ou encore
bruno le maire pourrait être débauché
pour rentrer au gouvernement faisant
céder la digue
audrey vettel première réunion de groupe
depuis l'élection d' emmanuel macron au
sénat les républicains s'affiche
ouvertement unis en rang pour mener la
bataille des législatives
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve
dans une famille unique j'insiste sur le
fait une famille unique parce que je
pense que si on laisse la place à l'est
l'opposant et de l'opposition à marine
le pen ou à monsieur mélenchon à ce
moment là dans cinq ans la seule
alternance possible ça sera les extrêmes
mais tous ne sont pas aussi disciplinés
comme le perçoit alain joyandet
bon je crois qu'il faut appeler achat
rachat à l'intérieur de la famille
politique a clairement une partie de nos
amis qui souhaitent
collaborer avec le nouveau président de
la république c'est leur responsabilité
une responsabilité que fabienne keller
assume pour faire avancer les choses
elle souhaite arrêter de s'opposer par
principe il y à aussi là la perspective
dans laquelle on se présente
est ce que c'est pour s'opposer au
nouveau gouvernement au nouveau
président ou est ce que c'est pour
défendre nos idées avec la perspective
de travailler avec pour roger karoutchi
il est beaucoup trop tôt pour prendre ce
genre de décision moi je propose que
chacune et chacun fasse des choix mais
plutôt à la fin de la séquence dire qu'
il serait bien le bec dans l'eau ce
qu'ils disent je vais chez mac ont tout
de suite shanghai législatives parce que
didier robert
alors on leur dira mais pas gagner à
tous les coups un dogue au revoir une
manière peut-être de sifflet
provisoirement la fin du match et de son
côté alain juppé ne veut pas d'opposer
asim d'opposition frontale à la
politique d'un gouvernement macron je
vous propose d'écouter tout cycle maire
de bordeaux laissait entendre que nous
étions quoi qu'il arrive destinée décidé
à nous engager dans une opposition
brutale et d'obstruction systématique
c'est pas ma disposition d'esprit tout
simplement parce que je pense qu'il faut
faire passer l'intérêt national avant
toute autre considération
voilà à partir de là l'exclusion est
toujours un aveu de faiblesse et on va
tout de suite à prendre la direction de
la rue de vaugirard où nous attend
savait rien roseq savait rien il ya un
bureau politique très attendu pour le
parti républicain
officiellement c'est pour voter sur le
programme des législatives le programme
doit être amendé mais on va évidemment
et bien parlé aussi de l'attitude à
adopter face à emmanuel macron
absolument delphine au menu vous l'avais
dit au menu ce bureau politique la
validation officielle du projet des
républicains pour les
jce l'atvs présenter rédigé par eric
woerth cette profession de foi sera
officiellement dévoilée à la presse
demain lorsqu'on nous explique ici c'est
que c'est en fait le programme fillon
qui a mené un programme allégé édulcoré
dans lequel ont été ajoutés quelques
propositions des juppéiste et bien sûr
des sarkozystes par exemple sur une des
promesses phares la réduction de 500
mille fonctionnaires et bien cette
promesse est maintenu mais à une
échéance beaucoup plus longue
en clair une plate forme générale
fillonniste mais avec de fortes
inflexion en faveur des classes moyennes
et populaires
alors au delà du programme vous l'avez
dit delphine là bien sûr dans toutes les
têtes
la recomposition ou bien la
décomposition des républicains un parti
désormais presque officiellement scindé
entre les légitimistes un retour du chef
de file françois baroin et je pense bien
sûr à valérie pécresse eric woerth ou
encore eric ciotti et puis les autres
les jus pays ceux encore qui n'ont pas
grand chose à perdre dans ces
législatives
tous ceux qui se laissent séduire ou se
laisserait séduire par la tentation
macron alors certains ont déjà franchi
le rubicon comme bruno le maire ou se
laisseraient tenter à travailler dans
une majorité de gouvernement comme
xavier bertrand fabienne keller ou
encore christian estrosi alors pour le
moment en face à cette tentation et bien
les digues tiennent comme nous l'a
expliqué à l'instant à des ténors du
parti mais delphine toute la question
bien sûr c'est pour combien de temps
merci beaucoup savaient rien on vous
retrouvera tout au long de cette édition
est la vague macron fait aussi des
remous front national après la défaite
de marine le pen l'heure est au bilan
un comité stratégique est en cours pour
ajuster la question des investitures
pour les législatives à nelson getten
deux jours après la lourde défaite du
front national au second tour
un conseil stratégique se réunit cet
après-midi au qg de campagne de marine
le pen à paris pour établir la stratégie
des législatives
critiqué par de nombreux membres du
parti florian philippot n'a pas vraiment
fait son mea culpa ce matin le projet là
législatif ce ne sont pas l'élection
présidentielle donc par définition
certains sujets peuvent être davantage
approfondi et tant mieux
je pense qu'il ya certains sujets qui
ont été trop absents de cette campagne
présidentielle et qu'on va et j'espère
que les initiatives permettront d'en
parler un peu plus de par exemple la
question de l'école par exemple la
question de la santé qui ferait qu'on
traite
c'est un peu une forme d'auto credo taux
critique non mais je veux dire bien sûr
qu'on peut toujours dire on peut faire
mieux on aurait pu faire mieux et c'est
bien sûr et pourtant c'est bien la ligne
du vice-président du front national qui
devrait être conservé pour la campagne
des législatives en interne
véritablement nous savons que le
programme de marine le pen et
l'organisation
les thèmes de la campagne les réflexions
de fond de la campagne sont dus pour une
très grande partie au talent de florian
philippot est à mon sens il n'y a
absolument pas lieu de remettre en cause
la position et les influences de florian
philippot et de ses idées du ce qu'il a
pu apporter au sein du front national le
profond renouvellement du parti annoncée
par marine le pen dimanche soir devrait
donc avoir lieu
mais après les législatives les
législatives c'est le troisième tour de
la présidentielle et ça s'annonce sous
tension alors que la victoire d'emmanuel
macro rebat les cartes on va tout de
suite en parler avec mes invités dans le
premier débat
[Musique]
et mes invités sur ce plateau françois
patriat bonsoir sénateur de la côte d'or
vous êtes un soutien de la première
heure des manuels macro merci d'être
avec nous jacky a également philippe
dominati bonsoir sénateurs les
républicains de paris également sur ce
plateau eric coquerel bonsoir je suis un
coordinateur et bien du parti dos vous
avez soutenu jean luc mélenchon pour la
france un smith dans cette élection
présidentielle jean messi a été
également sur ce plateau bonsoir vous
êtes coordination coordinateur national
du projet présidentiel de marine le pen
et puis emmanuelle grégoire bonsoir vous
êtes adjoint socialiste à la ville de
paris premier secrétaire de la
fédération de paris première question
pour vous d'ailleurs emmanuel grégoire
puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui est bien
manuel valls qui annonce vouloir faire
partie de la majorité présidentielle est
ce que il faut une clarification est
nécessaire quitte à signifier la mort du
parti social c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
dit m manuel valls matin oui donc on
comprend que c'est d'abord une
clarification vis-à-vis lui même
c'est une démarche quand on observe très
solitaire c'est une démarche de sauve
qui peut et d'ailleurs j'observe que ces
stratégies individuelles le monde hui ce
cas être éconduit quelle part les
socialistes et part en marche donc si ça
pouvait servir d'exemple à ceux qui
seraient tentés
je leur conseillerais de prendre un
petit peu de temps puisque manifestants
ils n'ouvrent pas je pensais pas suivi
sa position est extrêmement minoritaire
vert ce matin en bureau national la
condamnation a été quasi unanimes c'est
incompréhensible parce que le rapport de
force politique la logique des projets
la logique des engagements et des
valeurs c'est lorsque là on est ouvert
au dialogue c'est de le faire
collectivement et individuellement
vous n'êtes pas prêts à soutenir
emmanuel macron dans sa démarche c'est
bien je n'ai pas dit ça mais jeudi avant
de se poser la question de savoir si on
est ou pas dans la majorité faut d'abord
définir quelle majorité on entend
défendre sur quelle base programmatique
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet des élections
législatives de préciser les projets
législatifs que nous allons porter tous
les uns et les autres et c'est à partir
de cette clarification là que les
électeurs pourront se prononcer en
conscience
françois patriat on a vu que le
mouvement est bien la république en
marche accueilli plutôt fraîchement dans
cette candidature de manuel valls est ce
que vous souhaitez vous qu'il fasse
partie de cette majorité présidentielle
une règle la règle tous les candidats
qui souhaitent être république en marche
fasse acte de candidature et que cette
candidature serait examinée par la
commission et ensuite entérinées par le
comité politique
personne ne peut y échapper il ya des
marcheurs qui l'ont fait depuis
longtemps d'autres récemment mais ce que
je trouve ça c'est de la démarche n'est
pas solitaire vu le nombre de coups de
téléphone et de messages que j'ai reçus
ce matin
deux députés socialistes qui me disent
d'urgence qui sont vraiment très macro
nist et qu'il souhaite être candidat en
marche on va voir quels regards sont
portés justement sur ces cahiers plutôt
favorablement vous êtes plutôt sceptique
justement sur ces ralliements tarder
toute candidature est accueillie de même
façon que les autres hier avec nous pas
de repas de réserve en disant moi de la
situation de la deûle à ces
constructions
voilà le candidat qui a déjà été investi
s'il remplit les conditions c'est qu'il
a été effectivement très loyal et très
engagée pour emmanuel macron pourquoi le
déloger il peut y avoir un ou deux ou
trois cas particulier mais ça ça
appartiendra au comité politique de
trancher
c'est un peu ce qui est en train de se
passer à six films dominati au sein du
parti des républicains on voit et bien
certains parlementaires qui seraient
tentés par une aventure justement du
côté à des manuels macron oui en tout
cas on le dit mais pour l'instant on
chez les républicains on a un projet
législatif on a un chef de file qui est
françois baroin le programme le projet
des républicains a été établi depuis
longtemps même s'il a été légèrement
corrigé à l'issue de l'élection
présidentielle puisque ce n'est plus
tout à fait exactement techniquement le
même que celui de françois fillon m nous
avons un projet est pour l'instant on en
reste à ce projet on avait quand même
dans une situation très particulière
puisque si j'ai bien compris le
président la république va investir des
candidats et on ne connaît toujours pas
le nom du premier ministre qui va les
mener à la bataille est le président
mais ne sait pas encore la nature
politique de ce premier ministre on
évoque des noms aussi bien à droite
qu'au syndicat gauche et pour l'instant
c'est un peu curieux puisque finalement
jeudi on ne râle et candidat du
président mais on ne sait pas qui va
être leur chef de file pour les
élections législatives
chez nous au moins les choses sont
claires on a un patron qui est françois
baroin un projet qui a été établi depuis
longtemps
oui donc l'objectif c'est d'avoir un
gouvernement de cohabitation d'imposer
les français le souhaitent effectivement
peut-être que il y aura une cohabitation
où il y aura un élan porté par le
nouveau président de la république mais
là c'est aux français de décider c'est
pas nous nous ronge fait en tout cas en
ordre pour défendre nos idées et nos
convictions
c'est réellement le troisième tour de
cette élection présidentielle on sait
que jean luc mélenchon a tout à gagner
et tout à perdre aussi dans ces
législatives relief on a tout à gagner
bon ce soir du premier tour il ya
clairement en quatre poules dans ce pays
qui sont qui existe avec une
recomposition totale par rapport aux
deux parties qui étaient majoritaires
institutionnel on va dire que y'a le
pauvre qui continue la même politique
les deux quinquennats passé qui est
incarnée par cas par monsieur macron et
son mouvement en marche il ya le pôle
identité avec le front national
il ya ce que nous représentons c'est à
dire à paul solidaire de partage des
richesses à une autre une autre position
et je crois que rien n'a été réglé par
les présidentielles monsieur macro est
élu mais n'a pas de majorité politique
chacun en conviendra
et c'est effectivement législatives qui
décideront de la majorité finalement de
ce pays et ça se passera à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une première la vème
république
mais il faut s'y faire et pour notre
part nous nous y répondra sans lui notre
majorité son autre projet appelé bien
ses intentions elle veut être la
première force d'opposition pour le pays
ça passe aussi par une conquête une
bataille pour les législatives
comment s'y prépare t'elle on sait que
en ce moment il ya un comité stratégique
point ça pourrait être aussi compliquée
après son score pour elle de partir dans
cette bataille des législatives
non mais d'abord je veux répondre au
pôle identitaire ce que je crois vous
voyez pas bien regardé donc policiers
jour garçons
non mais vous m'avez pas bienvenus en
jeu
non mais je vous laisse indifférent cela
informations et publions mais là on a
d'autres projets on a si vous voulez là
l'exemple type 2 du régime des partis
que de la 4ème république en quelque
sorte c'est à dire qu'on a effectivement
une recomposition de la vie politique
les gens sont pas sur leurs idées ils
accourent auprès de monsieur macron pour
réclamer des investitures des postes
c'est parce que c'est la force devenu
majoritaire
donc tout ça n'a pas de sens je crois
que nous de notre côté on a on est
effectivement de facto le premier parti
d'opposition de france d'abord parce que
nous avons tenu tête à monsieur macron
jusqu'au bout les autres partis qu'on le
veuille ou non on soit appelé à voter
monsieur macron à au sort du 1er tour
soit ils l'ont aidé indirectement en
s'abstenant de voter contre
donc si vous voulez tout ça crée des
légitimités par la suite nous avons
effectivement la légitimité pour dire
que nous sommes le premier parti
d'opposition et nous entendons
effectivement à voir le nombre de
députés nécessaires en notre nom avec
debout la france pourrait sauter
majoritaire bah écoute et on verra on
verra mais de toute façon le scrutin
majoritaire joue pour tout le monde je
crois enfin pour tout l'est pour tous
les perdons entre guillemets et je crois
qu'on a avec 11 millions de voix au
deuxième tour on peut capitaliser là
dessus pour essayer de constituer un
groupe parlementaire assez large il y
aura des circonscriptions il y aura des
désistements en faveur des candidats de
vous la france
écoutez tout ça est en cours de
discussion je peux pas je peux pas en
dire plus mais forcément nous sommes
dans une alliance donc nous allons
composer un groupe souverainiste au sein
de l'assemblée qui sera la force
principale d'opposition à la politique
que mènera monsieur macro emmanuel
grégoire on sort d'un quinquennat
traumatisé par les frondeurs est ce que
ça ne va pas faire évoluer justement les
mentalités certains au sein du parti
socialiste parle d'une inconscience
collective si on continue justement eh
bien peut-être à ne pas faire d'accord
avec emmanuel macron d'abord je crois
que les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle du premier tour ont
envoyé un message clair aux socialistes
donc si ils n'avaient pas encore compris
il le serait temps de le faire
l'état d'esprit que moi j'ai observé ce
matin en bureau national a été celui un
de la prise de conscience et 2 d'éviter
de tomber dans le piège
le piège qui serait soit d'être dans une
opposition stérile soit dans d'être dans
un soutien sans condition et donc
l'objectif politique des jours à venir
et chacun chaque formation politique est
appelée à le faire et c'est pas qui sera
le meilleur opposant le premier opposant
le premier soutien et c'est ce qu'on
doit mettre à profit au cours des jours
qui viennent et de la campagne des
législatives
c'est une clarification sur les projets
politiques est ce que souhaite le parti
socialiste c'est en autonomie du
mouvement initié par le président de la
république contribué à faire en sorte
que ce pays pour les cinq prochaines
années soit utile à la france est soit
utile aux français et être utile à la
france et est utile aux français selon
nous je comprends que les avis divergent
puisse exister
selon nous c'est pesé pour le progrès
social
c'est pesé pour protéger les plus
faibles et les plus fragiles ceux que
nous considérons parfois que le
président élu a tendance à oublier
nous ne voulons pas être dans
l'opposition radicale nous voulons créer
les bases d'une discussion pour être
utile à la france et aux français
françois patriat c'est un risque de voir
ce groupe parlementaire ps de nouveaux
frondeur et kiffa s'est échouée qui m'a
des bâtons dans les roues aux réformes
annoncées par emmanuel maquet un peu
l'élargir voilà la question que tout
cela on a posé la question qu sûr que
sur monsieur valls il a quatre scénarii
est possible les scénarii de
l'opposition qui est incarnée par
nationale et par la france un sony c'est
pas comme ça que c'est le positionner
j'ai entendu
oui jean luc mélenchon vous savez -
choirat dit je suis dorénavant dans
l'opposition l'adage aux rites et médium
il a dit il a dit j'ai dans le positif
du post mais recruter moi j'ai entendu
ce que je voulais pas intérêt ensuite
vous avez ceux comme monsieur dominati
qui joue la cohabitation c'est à dire
immobilisme la stérilité
la cohabitation et puis il ya ceux comme
les amis du parti socialiste qui se joue
la coalition tout ça ça fait pas avancer
les choses
ce que les français veulent
sélectivement à mieux-être et une
amélioration de la condition de tout le
monde et pour que les gens pour qui et
du social pour qui et demain contre
occupent des plus pauvres il faut
d'abord qu'il y ait du travail dans ce
pays et pour qu'ils aient du travail
dans ce pays il faut que l'économie
fonctionne bien personnes exclues l'hôte
emmanuel macron diaby libéré protéger
donc tout dans le programme est ce que
nous souhaitons nous c'est pas ces
scénarios mi chèvre mi chou qui vont
cours bloquer des choses c'est d'avoir
ce que dit la vème république ce
qu'avait demandé le général de gaulle ce
qu'a fait françois mitterrand
ce café jacques chirac d'avoir une
majorité présidentielle capable
d'appliquer le programme que les
français ont plébiscité je les préviens
d'accord quand même le thème annuel
macro emmanuel macron a été lu par deux
français sur trois qui ont voté pas ce
sont mes chansons projet ne se sont pas
tout à fait mais sinon nous mais aussi
tout à fait abondance et je sais pas par
tout le monde c'est toi qui me sentais
un peu mieux il est le deuxième
président le mieux élu de la cinquième
rêve mais vous fait emprunter l'actif
regarder les musées du quota litis le
mahb a dit c'est qu'il a payé lui son
projet mais il n'a pas semblé monsieur
ne voudrais pas interrompu non mais
c'est un début nommé rester courtois
satin des brest et côtoie très bien mais
j'étais je suis parfaitement
arrivé premier avec près de 25% des voix
au premier tour
c'est quand même au premier tour le
projet d' emmanuel macron qui a séduit
le plus grand nombre de français que
vous le vouliez ou non mais c'est le
français est comme ça touche source la
saccharine lebel à 60% et ont voté pour
monsieur macron parce que c'est celui
qui a le plus séduit les français
les entraîner parce que gilles fonds qui
manquent de vous dans vos partis
traditionnels tels que nous les connu
qui j'étais dedans longtemps en voyant
et vous voyez on doit fonctionner y
compris vous la france telle qu'elle a
été pendant ces cinquante dernières
années et la force des manuels macro
déchets concerne d'abord première
première chose non peut évidemment pas
dire que sur mac on a une majorité fois
ci c à l'ombre
al'inverse de tous que du scrutin
d'accord vous avez quand même play près
d'un titre plus d'un tiers des français
qui se soit abstenue que soient vos
crocs voter blanc ou nul
vous n'avez vous savez très bien
attendez vous savez très bien que
quasiment la moitié des victoires de
monsieur mac on explique qu'il a voté
faire barrage au front national
donc c'est une grande erreur tu es
toujours comme des normes monsieur cema
comme toujours c'est pas comme ça et
vous le savez bien
d'ailleurs vous allez le voir au
législatif si vous le pensez pourquoi
parce que monsieur macron a eu 24 % des
voix il faudrait déjà se convainc que ça
n'a pas été une partie d'un vote utile
puisque déjà on appelait
à faire en sorte que monsieur mélenchon
soit pas au 2e tour parce que je sois
disant ils ne pourraient pas battre
madame le pen enfin on a eu tous ces
appels au vote utile sa fin se sont
laissé avoir
donc je pense que le projet de monsieur
mac aujourd'hui pas plus que le projet
de monsieur hollande dont il est le
continuateur empire une majorité
politique dans ce pays développés on nie
les faits rien que les faits quand je
trouve ça quand je dis ça je ne dis pas
que monsieur patriat a tort de défendre
son projet ça le regarde n'est pas le
mien je m'y oppose d'accord mais il faut
en convenir
et d'ailleurs nous verrons bien parce
que nous nous acceptons un le fait que
monsieur macro est élu il n'y a pas de
contexte mais par contre ces
législatives qui vont décider et c'est
là où je vous ai repris quand vous
disiez monsieur mélenchon et parler
d'opposition nous ne nous ne parlerons
pas du malheur défaitiste
nous estimons tous pour être majoritaire
en tout cas nous position pour
rassembler une autre majorité que celle
qui que présente monsieur macron d'un
point de vue du fond politique et par
rapport au front national c'est un peu
la différence c'est que le front
national quelquepart finances et une
opposition tranquille pour le système
il est toujours sûr de gagner au
deuxième tour non mais non les pensant
que législatives peuvent vous permet de
faire gagner notre projet et c'est ça
qui va être proposé en français
autrement dit nous disons français
rassemblés vous les 7 millions
d'électeurs qui ont voté pour nous plus
ceux qui étaient tentés de le faire
et oui une pour est majoritaire à
l'assemblée ou au moins nous pouvons
bloquer les projets national qu'il soit
dangereux pour le prier pour de ce bar
compte non monsieur on a appris à battre
la dame de fer s'est passé ça s'est
vraiment est ce que vous dites un sol
j'estime en vous êtes un danger avec
c'est vrai la république et que j'adore
gbola citoyens comme les médias non je
regarde les programmes vod
on va laisser la salle
sentiment que s'il vous plaît on va
laisser la parole à philippe dominati
on a l'impression aussi que la stratégie
des manières de diviser pour mieux
régner attitude ya aussi un risque
d'implosion peut-être chez les
républicains à 600 dons seront maquillés
d'inclusion chez les républicains il ya
des questions sur des problèmes de fond
et le débat démontre bien qu'il y a des
projets de gouvernement est en réalité
il ya pas 36 il y à celui de la majorité
présidentielle qui va se faire et
probablement celui que nous allons
proposer nous avec les républicains pour
essayer d'obtenir une contre majorité où
une majorité de cohabitation comme ça a
été très bien expliqué pour le reste il
peut y avoir des mouvements de
contestation et c'est des tentations qui
sont portées au moment des élections
légistatives les législatives peuvent
rééquilibrer la situation politique du
pays
et c'est une occasion nous nous avons un
projet qui a été développé à plusieurs
reprises mais vous allez la main lors
des élections j'ai essayé bien il n'a
pas permis ce projet à françois fillon
de jouter map avec un parti
effectivement qui a peut-être été
déficient un candidat qui n'a pas su
convaincre
néanmoins ce projet existe il a fait ses
preuves à au cours d'un certain nombre
d'élections que ce soit les les
européennes et régionales et une fois de
plus si le candidat de gauche lorsqu'il
reste à définir quel est le candidat que
nous avons aujourd'hui à la présidence
de la république
si c'est le candidat de gauche et il
semblerait quand même que ce soit le cas
on verra bien dans les investitures qui
sont données et le soin des plus passer
que parce que le front national
gerber le george v de droite emmanuel
macron vous mêmes c'est tout à l'heure
la prise de conscience
emmanuel grégoire dont cette prise de
conscience ce matin lors du bureau
national on a ce par quoi est ce que ça
passe aussi par un renouvellement des
instances dirigeantes au parti
socialiste on sait lieu il ya beaucoup
de critiques notamment sur jean
christophe cambadélis est ce que l'objet
est l'objet pas de personne à tisser je
veux dire c'est l'échec est largement
partagée dom et oui évidemment l'un des
symptômes de cette séquence politique
les primaires qu'elle soit de droite ou
de gauche l'élection présidentielle le
succès de représentation politique
extrême est un témoignage d'impatience
de colère et d'aspiration au
renouvellement pour le prendre de façon
de plus plus positive et donc évidemment
on ne va pas le faire demain ça prendra
du temps mais évidemment il faudra un
puissant mouvement de modernisation et
de revel renouvellement des formations
politiques sinon elle s'éteindront et ce
sera mérité
donc ce n'est pas mon sujet à ce stade
simplement sur le positionnement parce
que quand une fois revenir à ce qui est
l'essentiel c'est permettre aux citoyens
d'avoir un avis de se forger un jugement
éclairé
compte tenu des enjeux moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé la formule de françois patriat qui
a été socialiste
beaucoup plus longtemps sans doute que
je ne me serais jamais chacun
l'expriment comme il le souhaite vous
avez dit libéré et protégez moi j'ai
très bien vu que emmanuel macron voulait
libérer les énergies il l'a dit à
maintes reprises je crois en revanche
qu'il y a beaucoup de flou sur la
capacité à protéger les français et le
parti socialiste sa vocation
sa vocation pour que ce quinquennat soit
utile aux français et à la france y en a
certains qui diront que c'est manifester
dans la rue pour s'opposer
systématiquement à tous pas ma
conception de l'engagement politique
il nous arrive de le faire et je suis
persuadé que nous ferons nous l'avons
fait et nous le referons mais pour être
utile il faut porter une ligne politique
qui permet de rassurer de protéger de
favoriser le dialogue social n'a pas
trait comme on fait déjà pour désamorcer
peut-être là l'opposition à venir quand
on entend les propos d'emmanuel daiwa
dont les propos d'emmanuel primeur il
rien qui me choque a priori sauf que aux
jeunes après j'ai l'impression qu'une
impression ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
majorité à la carte
on va prendre ce qui nous arrange
la défense des intérêts d'untel ou
d'untel prendra les mesures qui
protègent les mesures qui libère on les
prendra pas j'ai entendu ce matin
or au cou ne suis pas y participer au
groupe des gens qui m'a dit j'ai soutenu
emmanuel macron mais je ne soutiendrai
pas telle ou telle chose
son programme n'a quand même pas déjà
entendu j'entends lui cela c'est donc
c'est ca soutient à la carte va pas
recommencer à se faire nos propres fonds
darcis jeu ils permettent pas d'avoir
commencé à faire l'essai c'est pour ça
que nous voulons une clarification
êtes vous oui ou non soutenez vous oui
ou non le projet emmanuel macron jeudi
que lille est dans l'opposition jean luc
mélenchon parce qu'il a dit qui manche
soir je suis opposé totalement au projet
d' emmanuel macron si c'est pas de
l'opposition celle l'occident ni
l'opposition majoritaire variable et
avez vous déjà à des vous déjà vu quand
même un président de la république
appelait avoir une majorité qui lui
permettent de ne pas gouverner
est-ce que isq hier les gens auraient
discuté pour georges pompidou pour
françois mitterrand de l'emballage rien
ne se passe comme amazon n'empêcha pas
sinon âgées n'empêche que cela
ce rythme là il a toujours été il a
toujours été d'actualité et les français
ou pas prendre les français pour des
gogos
ils vont pas voter un jour pour un homme
et un projet et lendemains d'hier va
voter pour annuler ce projet initial
lamela cet esprit là je prends ce qu'on
fait on les prend les français pour des
gogos parce qu'à la vérité en marche
ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un siphonnement
un siphonnage du parti socialiste vous
avez reconstituer le parti socialiste
les et tout le système en réalité en
train de s'agglomérer 189 le système que
vous 188 vous représentez que représente
aussi les républicains est en train en
réalité d'être par une chance aux plus
jeunes se reconstituer en un monobloc
d'où les ralliements de monsieur soral
de monsieur estrosi de monsieur bertrand
tu sais tout ça était très irritant
hétéroclite un rassemblant très
hétéroclite autour de monsieur macron
c'est la personnification du système
si on prend un petit peu une vision
géostratégique des choses ce système là
a été vaincu aux états unis il a été
vaincu en grande bretagne la
présidentielle a été la mère de toutes
les batailles parce que tout le système
à la fois politique et médiatique s'est
agglomérée pour éviter ce qui s'est
passé en grande bretagne aux états unis
et là vous constituer un bloc
un bloc qui une majeure virant présent
une majeure est tout le système des 40
dernières années aussi bien la droite
que la gauche en termes d'hommes
et aussi la politique qui a été menée
ces 30 dernières années et que vous
entendez s'est approfondie la
mondialisation vingtaine en l'europe
n'avait pas lu le programme des
manoeuvres étaient mentionnés sur ce
point non mais je vais la majorité c'est
le fait de dire qu' il revendique
d'essayer d'avoir une majorité
présidentielle ça c'est normal ils
veulent gouverner
bon moi ce que je crois par contre c'est
que il ya eu une entourloupe macro c'est
à dire que son programme était enrobé
dans un espèce de marketing jusqu'au
dernier jour et qui cache une réalité
pour beaucoup de français
la réalité c'est 125 mille
fonctionnaires en moins c'est le fait de
continuer des politiques d'austérité 60
milliards demandés aux collectivités
territoriales ans c'est le riche dit
monsieur seydoux et le fait c'est le
fait de continuer à vouloir déréguler le
marché by avec nous une mère l'oie
travail c'est le fait de s'attaquer aux
retraites 11 ans un système de retraite
à points et c'est donc il ya un projet
qui en gros la continuité pour aller
vite de ceux qui pensent que ce qui
coûte cher c'est le travail et nomma le
capital et non pas les bénéfices donc on
va continuer comme ça à faire en sorte
de baisser ce qu'ils appellent le coût
du travail en espérant que ça passe des
emplois de demain
c'est fait depuis 30 ans donc en réalité
cette vieille ficelle ils ont tout à
fait leur droit des sirènes majorité là
dessus moi ma conviction c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de majorité dans le pays
pour cette politique raison que nous
allons nous qu'il soit effectivement
dans une situation et je comprends le
problème partie ciel ce parti s'est
répercutée part ça il y à le faire cette
politique pendant cinq ans non monsieur
hollande on sait pas ce que a défendu
monsieur hamon du fait de la question de
la primaire et on voit bien que le parti
se fait aujourd'hui est au milieu du gué
ce n'est pas trop s'il va être opposant
pas opposants bon ça va dépendre
certainement de cette discussion à terre
nous nous sommes clairs voilà je pense
qu'il ya il est important je crois
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens que cette
législative soit l'occasion d'un débat
politique de fond sur ce que veulent les
uns et les autres et c'est là où vous
décidez des majorités bon nous nous
l'avons dit rien n'a été réglé par cette
élection il reste quatre forces qui ont
entre 19 et 21% des voix au soir du
premier tour
nous verrons bien celles qui sont
capables de rassembler pour proposer une
majorité par rapport à ce coup d etat
l'heure nous ne sommes pas seulement
contestation du système nous avons un
programme n'est pas d'accord avec nous
saper l'avenir en commun et très
cohérente où nous l'avons budgété donc
qui est l'inversé du vote mais en tout
cas au moins tout cas sur les
économiques et sociales et voilà il est
français vont choisir je pense qu'il
faut avancer dans cette élection de la
manière la plus démocratique et pour une
fois ce n'était pas plus mal que ce soit
la question parlementaire dans le régime
vicier la vème république qui va
trancher la question du choix police
philippe dominati signe c'était évoqué
il ya certainement aussi des ténors qui
vont avoir cette tentation macro comment
on fait pour y résister pour résister à
la tentation macron écoutez je crois que
je les dis et redis pour l'instant
d'abord attendons de voir quel sera le
programme elle projet présenté par le
président de la république et quel va
être le premier ministre pour mener
cette bataille des législatives
c'est une bataille des législatives nous
nous savons ce que nous voulons j'avais
en un projet qui consiste à réduire la
pression fiscale parce qu'elle a été
gravement augmenté sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français ces dernières
années et des les entreprises vont donc
sur le plan de l'économie c'est un
projet économique qui a été soulignée
tout à l'heure nous avons un projet pour
l'europe
nous avons un projet sur le plan
international notre projet il est
clairement défini constitution parce
qu'effectivement un certain dialogue est
établi manifestement entre le parti
socialiste et d'anciens membres du parti
socialiste pour voir si on peut
s'entendre sur un projet présidentiel
est effectivement eu le président en
choisissant le premier ministre va
choisir un premier ministre de gauche ou
pas et à partir de là un débat politique
va s'engager
nous nous avons des candidats partout
comme le parti présidentiel et nous
avons une plateforme à proposer aux
français pour les élections législatives
et cela elle n'a pas varié en fonction
des dernières heures
monsieur macro on le connaît c'est plus
d'immigration plus d'europe demandé de
régulation macro d'accord mais pas
d'arrogance parce que le vois je le vote
s'est arrêtée au second tour le 5 au 2e
tour donc c'est un nouveau d'un don nous
opposer et proposer d'autres choses mais
nous opposer quand nous pourrons le
faire puisque monsieur macron doit aussi
gouverner par ordonnances et capoeira ça
c'est pour le jeu pourrait ajouter non
législative alors c'est pas ce qu'il
fera de l'allemagne la grippe a le
sentiment que emmanuel macron veut
détruire le parti socialiste je ne sais
pas s'il en fait un point de départ
c'est pas mon sentiment mais simplement
il veut monter autour de lui une force
qui lui est totalement loyal totalement
dévoués comme le disait eric coquerel et
françois bas prix on ne peut pas lui
reprocher donc voilà il y là il fait son
aventure en la matière mais après les
français ils ont le choix de définir une
ligne politique parce que voilà on peut
faire de longs débats sur l'adhésion au
projet des manuels macron mais il est
très clair que ce n'est pas l'élément
structurant de l'élection présidentielle
chacun sait qu il ya eu des mécanismes
de vos tuiles très important et donc
maintenant il faut pouvoir rendre ce
quinquennat utile je le dis monsieur
coquerel avec tout le respect que je
vous dois
il n'y aura pas de majorité france 1
soumise à l'assemblée nationale ça
n'existera pas autre exemple de
soumission pour une raison simple pour
une raison simple on est même pas
capable de faire un accord avec le parti
communiste sur concert ça soumise la
venue des discussions sentez vous que
vous gérez les doutes mais ils feront
d'ailleurs en page deux majorités
présidentielles françaises soumises
chaque un retour aux tno vous le sujet
est ce que le vote des français est
utile et le travail d'un parlementaire
c'est de fabriquer la loi c'est pas de
manifester dans la rue contre le
président de la république
donc c'est comment on fait en sorte que
les neuf accusés d'accord il surgit
je ne sais rien j'en sais rien dans sa
carrière je le sais je le savais mais
non là
les électeurs ne le savaient pas
qu'elles se soient les précisions qu'il
y apparaît vous y être opposés
systématiquement et c'est ce qu'on vous
reproche
vous êtes dans l'opposition et qui sait
si on nous reprochait pas si c'est juste
pour avoir une maison bbc s'était sans
doute pour des raisons quand ils
existent universel vient de trancher si
on est d'accord avec emmanuel sont
justement vis à vis à vis du parti
socialiste certains disaient il faut et
bien réduire au maximum le nombre de
parlementaires de dieu on en aura besoin
pour faire tourner l'assemblée nationale
assure le ps août cassiers les
républicains ou d'autres je veux
répondre à me suis confiée à l'instant
que quoiqu'il lui dit et il a pas tord
complètement que de faire 19% des voix à
la présidentielle c'est un grand succès
il existe un vrai succès je me dis mais
par contre emmanuel macron fait 24 %
c'est un échec
en bref on va savoir un peu ce qu'on dit
nous mêmes messages david glazier pas
d'autorité mais vous l'avez pas nous
énerver pas qu'il n'avait pas vu le gall
heureux de l'année c'est pour ça que
vous l'aurez jamais non mais chez vous
monsieur déjà fait on a été en déficit
vous étiez déjà très méprisons par
rapport à la présentons un magasin quand
on a une vision de français va gagner
contre et attention à ce que les sept
maris déchets j'ai dit à mon permis de
faire barrage par rapport au final pour
une tranche artesia d'il ya quatre ans
ça va aussi voir il ya des limites
devant alors allez-y ans à l'entrée à
meymac et son fils emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui il a derrière lui ce qu'ils
pensent à leur boutique
il pense à la france pour condamner la
france il veut la faire évoluer la faire
sortir du marasme et leur reconduire sur
le chemin de la croissance la france
pour ce faire j'avais le pm veaux des
républicains la france a soumise tout ça
c'est lui le seul clivage qui le voit
dans ce pays c'est de rassembler les
gens qui sont des progressistes contre
ceux qui sont des conservateurs et je
regrette messieurs vous appartenez tous
avec vos méthodes à la lisière
d'habitude aux conservateurs mais c'est
ça aujourd'hui c'est ça qui a séduit les
français
pas facile il suffit que les gens de
bonne volonté de progrès se réunissent
portrait moi je n'ai pas de problème je
suis je suis socialiste et zoellick
je suis aujourd'hui en marche mais il ya
des gens de droite avec qui je peux
travailler parce que je pense quand une
vraie forme est bonne pour le pays
bonne pour l'économie bonne pour les
travailleurs bonne pour les salariés
bonne pour l'écologie si la droite le
propose ici la gauche tient c'est bien
monsieur jusqu'à présent non ça mais si
on a des alternants stérile voire mais
si ça serait quoi il aurait une russie
le jour dès les essais 3 par la droite
et par la gauche et tout le monde le
sait arrêté szczesny que j'ai souvent
parlé même personne n'ignore pas votre
moulin à paroles
non mais soyons passé mais prison vous
allez déchanter bientôt ça c'est quoi un
site pour vous justement législatives ou
est-ce que vous placez le curseur par
rapport au nombre de députés écoutez ça
sert il appartient aux français d'en
décider et nous nous en présenter des
députés partout le évidemment le but
c'est d'avoir le la major fin en tout
cas le groupe parlementaire le plus
large possible pour essayer
effectivement de défendre la france que
qui vient d'être qualifié de boutiques
par le représentant du président de
république
donc nous pour nous c'est pas une giclée
partie oui non non les marques c'est ben
ali la france
ça va venir à vous mais ça c'est très
c'est très symptomatique si ça vous
intéresse
laurent qui vient de s'exprimer
justement il appelle à un large
rassemblement on écoute tout de suite
est le secrétaire national du parti
communiste il y a une nouvelle chance
avec l'élection présidentielle avec
l'élection législative d'aller disputer
la majorité parlementaire
on ne comprendrait pas que on ne
permettent pas à toutes les forces
d'aller ensemble à cette bataille et
qu'on privilégie des objectifs
d'installation partisane donc moi je dis
il est temps encore il ne reste pas des
jours et des jours ça se joue dans les
heures qui viennent mais il est temps de
voilà de revenir à la discussion sur
l'ensemble sur un périmètre plus large
peut-être pas on n'arrivera pas au point
où on en est à toutes les
circonscriptions
mais un très grand nombre de
circonscriptions oui c'est possible eric
coquerel ça pourrait coûter cher à la
france insoumise s'il n'y a pas d'accord
législatif avec le parti communiste
écoutez je vais vous dire une chose
moi je suis un des initiateurs du front
de gauche d'accord le front de gauche a
été incapable de transformer les 11% de
jean luc mélenchon par la suite en à
succès pourquoi parce qu'il restait à
cartel de partie avec une addition des
tic est bien chacun a fait pendant cette
campagne présidentielle différents choix
par en plus nos camarades du parti
commission décide soutien d'une hanche
en mai
être dans la démarche française soumises
qui en gros se résume à une stratégie un
programme et le fait de vouloir
l'adhésion directe c'est à dire le fait
qu'on puisse la dir est directement un
mouvement sans faire partie d'un parti
ou pas et de pesée de la même manière
maintenant il ya le résultat à la fin
moi ce que je dis à nos camarades
communisme a d'autres qui pourraient
être intéressées y compris pour ceux qui
par exemple ont soutenu monsieur amant
qui manière sincère on vit une petite
totalement différente de celle monsieur
macron jeudi qu' on ne va pas nous
changer une méthode qui a fait ses
preuves
voilà on vous le connaissez maintenant
il n'y a pas d'exemple dans la vème
république
c'est mon compte il n'y a pas d'exemple
la série au public entre la campagne
présidentielle accompagné ce natif avec
un mouvement comme ça qui changera
d'étiquettes de nos deux programmes et
c'est parce que ça c'est la meilleure
manière d'avoir des accords à géométrie
variable de perturber nos concitoyens et
de ce point de vue là c'est vrai que il
ya une des marques qui ressemble un peu
à celle de deux rangs marche qui est le
fait de dire nous avons une cohérence
nous la présentons et nous nous fichons
de savoir qui est militant ou pas dans
la cette main tendue
la réserve ses traits les noms pierre
sait très bien que la main et j'ai
entendu dire il ya beaucoup de
communistes qui sont déjà en france a
soumis il ya des écologistes il ya même
des socialistes
il ya des il ya des membres de deux ans
ans il ya différentes formes éthique
beaucoup de syndicalistes et nous nous
disons à nos amis communistes
venez rejoindre pour construire ce que
nous essayons faire parce qu'on essaye
non seulement de recomposer le pays mais
on pense que je le répète complète
majoritaire c'était un grand espoir
comment dire france a soumis ce n'est
pas un parti c'est une démarche
mouvement et on invite tout le monde à
le rejoindre
voilà je pense que c'est emmanuelle
grégoire vous avec les écologistes ces
communistes qui ne se retrouverait pas
dans la france un sou mais ça pourrait
aussi constituer une nouvelle force à
gauche écoutez oui enfin
d'abord je pense que c'était surtout un
message pour la france insoumise et ça a
été très élégamment fait mais c'était
effectivement une fin de non recevoir
que vient de formuler eric coquerel
parce que c'est un ralliement par heinze
et sans conditions s'y passe est
manifestement celle des communistes pour
ceux qui m'en parlent
moi ce que je sais c'est que la gauche
parfois lorsqu'elle est en dynamique
elle sait gagner car monsieur coquerel a
été élu sur une liste rassemblement de
la gauche
derrière les socialistes comme quoi
quand c'est important c'est possible
nous avons des expériences
de la gauche en responsabilité dans les
exécutifs locaux c'était votre cas je
crois monsieur patriat c'est notre cas à
la ville de paris
c'est un bien très précieux pour les
projets politiques que nous avons
présentés démocratiquement aux citoyens
et donc moi je pense qu'il ne faut
fermer aucune porte à la discussion et
donc les jours à venir il faudra voir
comment le sens des responsabilités
inspire chacun et j'espère que ça
permettra d'offrir un autre pays une
majorité large de progrès qui sera utile
de lui on se souvient de françois bayrou
en 2007 est arrivé et ça a été ça ne
s'est pas traduit en six native avec
seulement une poignée de parlementaires
comment éviter que ce scénario se
reproduise
justement avec votre parti cette année
écoutez d'abord il ya une implantation
locale et des idées relativement clair
qu'ils sont des idées de gestion et de
me des bêtises des modérés nous nous
voulons avoir une opposition modérée et
si possible convaincre pour avoir une
majorité pour gouverner le pays
pour cela on est capable d'avoir les
hommes pour faire un gouvernement
derrière françois baroin c'est
relativement simple
autrement on sera probablement le
principal bloc d'opposition peut-être
constructive sur un certain nombre de
points si ça libère l'économie pourquoi
pas et peut-être plus critique sur un
certain nombre de points
si c'est pour persévérer dans la
politique du quinquennat précédent
c'est relativement simple nous pouvons
ne pas y arriver parce qu'effectivement
il peut y avoir des forces qui vont
dissiper je dirais est éparpillé
l'électorat créer un certain nombre de
triangulaires ou de quadrangulaires au
moment des élections législatives fin de
ce débat merci à tous les cinq à avoir
participé en vue de continuer cette
analyse puisque on retrouve sa verrière
ogec qui nous attend et bien depuis la
rue de vaugirard vous êtes alors que le
bureau politique de l air est en train
de se terminer savait rien
absolument delphine au menu de ce bureau
politique le programme des républicains
pour ces élections législatives mais
au-delà de ce programme il ya bien sûr
dans toutes les têtes
donc toutes les têtes la recomposition
la décomposition du parti un parti de
plus en plus scindé entre les
légitimistes regroupés autour du chef de
file françois baroin et puis les autres
un tous ceux qui se laissent séduire par
la tentation m'accroche propose
d'ailleurs d'écouter à ce sujet luc
chatel qui s'exprimait à l'instant
et moi je suis pas dans une logique de
procès de moscou ça jamais été ma fille
m'a bien les exclus mais en même temps
moi je crois plutôt à la démarche
collective aux démarches individuelles
la démarche collective c'est de se dire
on est derrière nos candidats aux
législatives
on les soutient on fait en sorte que les
français votent pour nos candidats et
c'est les français qui doivent décider
moi je crois que la clarification la
recomposition c'est aux français de
décider
voilà pas d'anathème pas de procès de
moscou position exactement similaire
pour christian estrosi qui s'est exprimé
juste après certains parlent d'exclusion
jeudi que le premier mot à prononcer au
terme de cette élection ces
rassemblements si c'est pour radicaliser
comme nous avons radicaliser élections
présidentielles et bien les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets tout
simplement
après l'échec des présidentielles ce
sera l'échec des législatives
et c'est bien pour cela que j'appelle
plutôt rassemblement au respect de ceux
et celles qui voudront accompagné des
réformes dont notre pays a besoin plutôt
que de jeter des anathèmes sur eux merci
merci savait rien pour toutes ces
précisions on va continuer ce débat et
on va tout de suite retrouvé thème tran
huy à qui elle nous attend depuis à la
maison de la mutualité
on sait que jean christophe cambadélis
doit s'exprimer d'ici quelques instants
c'est à vous tam
oui effectivement jean christophe
cambadélis doit s'exprimer dans quelques
instants sur cette plateforme commune du
parti socialiste et 577 candidats aux
législatives du mois de juin en clair
sur ce qui rassemble un tous ses
représentants du parti socialiste sur la
ligne politique sur le projet mais voilà
très difficile un d'en parler cet après
midi alors que manuel valls ce matin
l'ancien premier ministre a annoncé a
choisi ce jour pour annoncé sa défection
du parti socialiste est pour dire qu'il
rejoignait pour les législatives les
rangs de la république en marche alors
ici les cadres du parti socialiste nous
on dit beaucoup qu'ils en avaient assez
un de répondre à des questions sur
l'ancien premier ministre il en avait
assez de devoir répondre à des questions
sur les postières ils veulent parler du
fond reste que c'est bien sûr l'ancien
premier ministre qui ils ont été
questionnés écouter d'ailleurs à ce
propos la réaction de mathieu hanotin
très en colère à l'égard de manuel valls
mathieu anota l'ancien directeur de
campagne de benoît hamon dans la
campagne présidentielle
d'autres disent que le parti socialiste
est mort quelle est votre réaction
oui bah vous c'est vous connaissez les
pompiers pyromanes donc moi j'ai jeu je
ne trouve pas ça très respectueux pour
tous les militants de gauche sincère
engagé qu'il faille refonder le parti
socialiste à l'évidence
voilà mais je trouve ça un petit peu
comment dire ironique dans le mauvais
sens du terme que soit ce qui fait le
plus de mal au parti socialiste et
provoqué la situation dans laquelle on
est arrivé aujourd'hui qui décrète que
le parti ali ça vaut plus rien alors que
le parti sioniste leur a tout donné
depuis des années
vous avez donc entendu la colère de
mathieu hanotin à l'égard de l'ancien
premier ministre manuel valls ici
beaucoup expriment de la déception mais
tous ne parlent pas de trahison certains
disent même comprendre qu'ils veulent
choisir à un chemin différent et
respecter ce choix car il est vrai qu'il
ya une chose qui n'est pas tranchée
c'est bien l'attitude à adopter par
rapport à la politique du nouveau
président de la république
emmanuel macron est d'ailleurs bernard
cazeneuve le premier ministre qui a été
longuement applaudie à une
standing-ovation lors de cette réunion
tout à l'heure a dit une seule chose
c'est qu'il fallait de l'apaisement en
l'écoutant
l'essentiel c'est la réussite du pinard
c'est le rassemblement
de notre famille pour
sa portée ça qu'on fait
c'est la nécessité
de moderniser et pour cela
profession ou sans son voilà qui résume
donc toute l'ambiguïté un du parti
socialiste par rapport à la tentation
emmanuel macron bernard cazeneuve veut
bien la réussite de ce quinquennat tout
en étant plus socialiste que jamais
merci beaucoup
tam et on attend et bien l'intervention
la conférence de presse de
jean-christophe cambadélis pour en
parler et bien j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir bruno cautrès bonsoir que
sur cher au cnra ce nombre du cevipof
merci d'être avec nous denis baron c'est
également sur ce plateau bonsoir vous
êtes professeur de droit public à paris
ii panthéon assas et puis notre
chroniqueur politique mickaël szames s
bonsoir de public sénat on a entendu
bruno cautrès ce matin un manuel valls
dire le ps est mort le ps est derrière
nous est-ce que ce soir jean-christophe
cambadélis peu et bien encore accès de
la survie de son parti a sans doute
qu'il va essayer bien sûr on le comprend
dans la situation où le parti socialiste
il va tenter de montrer que le parti
socialiste peut encore essayer de sauver
les meubles aux élections législatives
parce qu'il s'agit quand même avant tout
de ça dans ces élections législatives
apparaissent comme un champ de bataille
très difficile pour le parti socialiste
on peut s'attendre à l'issue des
législatives à ce que le parti
socialiste perdent un certain nombre de
grandes figures cueillez ddd des barons
du parti socialiste vraiment des hommes
et des femmes politiques auxquels nous
sommes habitués qui perdent leurs sièges
de députés donc jean christophe
cambadélis n'a pas tellement d'autres
solutions que d'essayer de faire ce
qu'il peut dans une situation est
extrêmement extrêmement difficile le
candidat du parti a eu 6 % à la
présidentielle
il voit au fond d une situation
absolument inédite le parti socialiste
qui devient une force de gauche presque
d'appoint dont quelque chose qui est
littéralement vertigineux pour
l'histoire politique française des
trente ou quarante dernières années et
on a un parti socialiste qui est
effectivement à reconstruire alors le
problème pour eux c'est qu'ils sont pas
d'accord sur le sens de la
reconstruction et sur le mot
reconstruire qu'est ce qui veut dire
jeudi c'est parce qu'on trois ou quatre
blocs maintenant à vous avez d'un côté
d'elle gauche dont ceux qui avaient voté
avec benoît hamon est ce qu'ils ont fait
était extrêmement fidèle à benoît hamon
pendant toute la campagne électorale et
qui tiennent absolument aujourd'hui
avoir le programme de benoît hamon être
incarné pour les futures législatives
alors que justement ou au bureau
national du parti socialiste ce matin on
a acté ce que finalement le programme de
benoît mot était totalement ou presque
écartés et mis sur le côté pour revenir
à des choses peut-être plus basiques et
notamment qui peut-être pourrait être
enclin à discuter avec emmanuel macron
et puis vous avez donc au milieu
cette droite un peu plus haute cette
gauche droite se plus centriste avec
manuel valls qui se dirige vers emmanuel
macron et vous avez encore une fois d'un
autre côté quelqu'un comme bernard
cazeneuve qui essaye de faire le grand
écart qui ont un peu les hommes
élastique pour essayer de ramener tout
le monde au sein de la maison pour que
justement cette maison ne s'effondre pas
c'est un jeu complètement presque fou et
qu'on dise qu'on est en train de voir
sous nos yeux
aujourd'hui c'est un party parti de
historique qui va prendre sa facture on
évoque là le cas du parti socialiste
d'une manière plus générale on voit
cette difficulté pour emmanuel macron
d'avoir une majorité dans une mise
beaucoup sur la logique des institutions
certains de ses arguments
on n'a jamais vu et bien un président
élu ne pas bénéficier de la dynamique
des électeurs à cette fois que ça
pourrait être très bien totalement
différent c'est logique de la vème
république jusqu'à maintenant c'était
que les français donnait une majorité
présidentielle au président élu
est ce que cette logique va se continuer
en juin ça reste à voir
et en réalité ce qui me semble assez
frappant c'est que personne n'a beaucoup
d'options clair si vous regardez
monsieur macro est constitué d'un
mouvement qui s'appelle en marche qui
réunit beaucoup de gens très différente
monsieur cohn-bendit monsieur berrou
rebaptisé la république en mal c'est un
mouvement c'est pas un parti ça n'a pas
les structures d'un parti et c'est pas
homogène idéologiquement
donc même si la veille c'est de
seulement 89 députés
est ce qu'il arrivera à gouverner avec
une majorité structure et je ne suis pas
absolument certain de l'autre côté vous
avez les républicains qui ont peut-être
des chances d'avoir entre 270 et 280
députés ils ont exactement le même
problème qui a été décrit pour le
s ils sont trois curés sont gravement
fracturait n'y a pas d'unité entre le
parti de monsieur wauquiez et le parti
de monsieur juppé madame kosciusko
morizet donc en réalité nos habitudes de
raisonnement en termes de blocs en terme
de parties contre parti ou coalition
contre coalition sur mon avis périmés et
c'est un grand point d'interrogation que
ces élections de juin alors il faudra
toujours on est quand même à l'intérieur
de la vème république c'est à dire que
l'articulation entre le pouvoir exécutif
et sa majorité au parlement est
absolument essentiel dans ces
institutions
donc évidemment c'est tout à fait
essentielle par contre c'est comment on
arrive à la majorité qui va peut-être
être différent jusqu'à présent on avait
connu deux grandes phases pour moi on
avait une phase de la vème république un
peu de départs la politique des deux
blocs avec à l'inter de chacun développe
un acteur dominant et puis à partir du
début des années 90 ces deux blocs se
sont transformés en trois pôles avec le
front national mais qui lui n'arrivait
pas à trouver des débouchés à
l'assemblée nationale
et maintenant on a vu après deux blocs
après trois pôles en est à quatre pattes
d'une certaine manière
donc on est dans une phase de
recomposition qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire à avoir qui se fait sous
nos cieux je pense que l'une des
difficultés à la fois pour ce
qu'analysent est sans aucun doute pour
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire cette
part de l'histoire la 5ème république
c'est que le phénomène en marche et
maquereau est un processus est en train
de se développer de se faire sous nos
yeux et ce qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est qu'au moment où ce
phénomène apparaît il apparaît en même
temps à son plus haut niveau c'est à
dire ils gagnent directement l'élection
numéro un et ils passent directement on
va dire du du plancher au plus haut
niveau donc on a un phénomène qui est en
train de se passer sous nos yeux et qui
tout à fait est en train de re compose
en profondeur les blocs les coalitions
alors la gauche et la droite n'ont pas
dit non plus totalement leur dernier mot
pas non plus les intérêts trop vite on
évoquait jean christophe cambadélis
il est de plus en plus contestée en
interne avec une demande d'un
renouvellement aussi des pratiques un
changement de direction week end
oui c'est vrai dit en interne ils eurent
demandé à renouveler en lui les
évidemment il veut absolument garder ce
poste de premier secrétaire mais il est
prêt à faire des concessions
visiblement ce qu est ce qui est en
train de se dessiner aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y aurait cinq personnalités issues
un peu de toutes les branches du parti
socialiste qui ferait une espèce de de
direction collégiale peut-être de la
nouvelle génération pense notamment à
matthias fekl qu'aujourd'hui ministre de
l'intérieur il ya najat vallaud-belkacem
le carré d'as sénateurs qui pourrait
incarner un petit peu cette nouvelle
génération de direction du parti
socialiste
ils essayent évidemment de garder toutes
ses possibilités et d'être un petit peu
au dessus de la mêlée jean christophe
cambadélis contesté également parce
qu'il est candidat aux élections
législatives contestés dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris
face à un candidat dans marche qui
visiblement lui causent de gros ennuis
et donc il ferait peut-être mieux lui
aussi de prendre un peu de recul
s'il veut pouvoir gagner ces élections
législatives et se concentrer sur cette
élection
c'est ce qu'on lui dit en tout cas en
interne au parti socialiste aucune
grande réflexion autour de la direction
de ce parti aujourd'hui qui est rappelle
déjà d'une part fracturée mais qui
risque peut-être de connaître sa plus
grosse perte depuis 1993 où il avait eu
55 députés
s'il tombait en dessous ça serait un
échec incroyable pour le parti peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils emmanuel macron a
obtenu déjà un petit peu le scalp du
parti socialiste et qui vise aujourd'hui
le scalp de la droite est-ce que c'était
voulu ça michael szames us de la part d'
emmanuel macron vraiment bien cette
extermination de tous les parlementaires
socialistes parce qu'on sait qu'il y
avait un débat au sein du mouvement en
marche ce qu'il faut et bien justement
complètement à éradiquer le mouvement ou
garder encore quelques périodes le
menteur expérimenté pour faire tourner
aussi l'assemblée ils vont les avoir ces
parlementaires expérimentés c'est ce qui
m'aime me suive
c'est un peu ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron si vous voulez continuer
avec moi et bien vous signé la charte
vous êtes donc de la majorité
présidentielle la de la république en
marche comme elle s'appelle aujourd'hui
si vous voulez pas c'est trop tard tant
pis pour vous sahil amis il a mis les
choses sur la table et c'est ça qui a
fait que les parties sont en train de se
fracturer
c'est vrai on le voit aujourd'hui à
droite alain juppé ouvre une porte cet
après-midi en disant qu'il peut y avoir
une forme de coexistence pacifique entre
nous et de partir de là on imagine que
les vannes vont s'ouvrir aussi peut-être
de ce côté là dès ce qu'on appelle de
neil droite de des centristes de la
droite
et là il est en train peut-être de
chambouler encore une fois le champ
politique
le champ des partis c'est là dessus
aussi qu'il a été lui donne une barre en
gironde évoquer ces scénarios possibles
soit effectivement aller français le
suivait dans les majorités absolues soit
il ya cette majorité de coalition ou
alors on en vient à la cohabitation
comment sentez vous les choses si on
aurait justement à le scénario qui
pourrait être le plus favorable emmanuel
macron la cohabitation est possible
socialement avec les républicains on la
voit mal les socialistes ils auront
probablement pas les résultats
électoraux qui permet de sa cohabitation
est possible avec les républicains mais
pour revenir à ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure je vois quand même mal une
cohabitation de blocs comme celle de 86
62 93 c'est pratiquement impossible vous
voit ici quand même lente de choc des
primaires c'est l'évincer des grands
vaincus des primaires maintenant qu'ils
sont prêts à constituer d'un côté la
droite raisonnable pour reprendre le
propos de monsieur juppé de l'autre une
gauche raisonnable c'est à dire monsieur
valls qui veulent bien travaillé et
s'ils le veulent
on voit quand même un petit effet de
revanche on voit quand même qu'ils en
veulent à leur parti qu'ils en veulent à
ce système qui la da qui les a écartés
ensuite ce qui pourrait bien arriver
c'est alors la cotisation est pas
impossible cela étant même avec un dlr
qui serait fort ce qui pourrait bien
arriver c'est ce qu'on appelait sous la
quatrième république des majorités
d'idées c'était une phrase des gars fort
c'est à dire au fond il y avait la
majorité scolaire la majorité européenne
majorité pour faire échouer la céder en
54 on pourrait aller vers ça d'autant
plus que programme de monsieur max n'en
est rien moins que parfaitement claires
et que très probablement il ajustera en
fonction de son mouvement et en fonction
des gens qu'il attirera
à l'intérieur nous marchons donc au fond
pour en revenir à des choses que les
spécialistes de 5e sont pas habitués à
voir
c'est à dire des concentrations comme on
disait sous la troisième république
un centre face à des extrêmes et puis
des majorités d'idées
parce qu'alain juppé cautrès pas
d'obstruction systématique n'est
d'opposition frontale ça va changer ça
dans la pratique du pouvoir selon vous
ça va changer en même temps il faut voir
qu'on a un moment très particulier c'est
à dire on est juste après le choc que
viennent de recevoir les partis
traditionnels de l'élection des manuels
macron et il y as quand même un peu une
dimension de jeu stratégique aussi dans
ce qu'on est en train de voir
je dirais pas que ces examens poker mon
coeur d'un menteur mais sent quand même
un peu un jeu stratégique parce que pour
emmanuel macron il peut y avoir quand
même une gamme de scénario il ya moi ce
que j'appellerais scénario plus plus il
a gagné l'elysée il a une majorité
absolue
il ya le cédant aux puces - il a gagné
l'elysée en marche et le principal bloc
principal groupe à l'assemblée nationale
mais n'est pas en majorité absolue il ya
le scénario qui commence à être plus
difficile qui le scénario plus - il à
l'elysée et puis il a un groupe en face
de lui qui est un groupe de droite par
exemple qui est en nombre
et puis il ya le scénario ou lac est
beaucoup plus difficile cohabitation
alors effectivement je pense que la
cohabitation telle qu'on l'a connue
jusqu'à présent n'est sans doute pas le
scénario le plus probable mais l'autre
scénario qui est en marche à un gros
groupe de députés mais peut-être pas le
principal groupe de députés ne serait
sans doute pas le scénario préféré des
manuels macro et réintroduire est tout
de suite une nouvelle interprétation du
jeu stratégique auquel on en train
d'assister qui est mais finalement
peut-être qu'on collabore pas avec le
président mais que c'est lui qui doit
venir vers notre programme dont il ya
tout un jeu comme ça en ce moment qui
emmanuel macron qui diva venait vers moi
qui m'aime me suive et les autres qui
disent pourquoi pas mais en espérant
qu'à un moment donné ça va peut-être
venir en sens inverse qui est mais c'est
peut-être au président aussi de venir
sur notre terrain de jeu week-end à
s'envoyer aussi que les républicains
sont réunis en bureau politique là aussi
ça tangue un peu à droite la tentation
macron elle est là elle existe qu'elle
peut faire aussi les mêmes ravages entre
guillemets qu'au sein du parti
socialiste appelle ça du début
jeux individuels d'autres peut-être un
affluent en masse on va voir jusqu'où ça
peut aller
ils disent eux que ça dépendra un petit
peu de la nomination du premier ministre
que choisira emmanuel macron ce qui est
sûr aujourd'hui c'est que il y à un
appel d'air qui a été qui a été lancé on
voit bien il ya eu des émotions des
hameçons qui ont été lancés ce qu'ils
vont les attraper et bien vous allez
dans cette majorité républicaine que
vous constituez emmanuel macron à partir
de là il ouvrira un champ des possibles
entre la droite la gauche le centre tout
sera un petit peu rebattu est donc là à
partir de là il y aura ce que parce que
vous avez 10 de la déclaration d'alain
juppé pour moi cette déclaration elle
ouvre une porte il qu'ils n'avaient pas
été ouvertes jusque là et qui a vraiment
sont importants ce soir parce qu'il dit
on est prêt à travailler ensemble il
tend une main
emmanuel macron avait tendue également
la main peut-être qu'ils sont prêts à se
serrer la main vous savez qu'on parle
beaucoup il ya des supputations de
nombre va lâcher tous les noms ici de
possibles premier ministre mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait un fidèle d'alain
juppé qui est sur les rangs qui était
noir philippe si un homme comme edouard
philippe devient prémunissent il est
évident que ce qui était proche d'alain
juppé vont le suivre vont suivre cette
personnalité traite à travailler tous
s'en sont alors on va continuer ce débat
mais je vous propose de retourner devant
la maison de la mutualité puisque
sandrine mazetier et au micro de thème
traduit ses tabous oui sandrine mazetier
vous venez de vous réunir alors cette
réunion justement au palais de la
mutualité comment est-ce que ça s'est
passé ce moment de rassemblement percuté
bien sûr parle annonce de manuel valls
de ce matin écoutez ça s'est très bien
passé d'abord cette réunion était
ouverte par un discours de bernard
cazeneuve qu est le premier ministre que
nous a rassemblés
depuis qu'il est en responsabilité à
matignon et même avant lorsqu'il était
en responsabilité dans les différents
ministères qui l'a occupée depuis 2012
il ya eu ensuite une intervention de
najat vallaud belkacem et c'était deux
visages de beaux visages du socialisme
utile aux français d'une gauche qui veut
imaginer se confronter au réel trouver
des solutions et construire un autre
modèle de développement qui soit durable
donc c'était un moment de grande
responsabilité de soulagement aussi
parce que nous avons beaucoup plus vrai
pour que marine le pen soit réduite au
maximum au deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles donc soulagement et
volonté d'être une gauche authentique
tourné vers l'avenir
vigilante pour protéger des français
pour porter les solutions de demain
le parti socialiste n'est pas mort comme
l'a dit ce matin manuel valls ou encore
didier guillemin le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat
écouter s'il ya peut-être des personnes
qui sont mortes au parti socialiste mais
non le parti socialiste n'est pas morts
on annonce sa mort à peu près avec la
régularité d'une horloge et tel un
phénix le parti socialiste renaît de ses
cendres
écoutez là il y avait des candidats des
candidats des membres du gouvernement d
militantes et des militants aussi avec
la ferme volonté d'être ni dans une
forme d'opposition systématique et
stérile ni dans un caporalisme qui n'a
rien de moderne
justement cette ligne n'est pas très
claire par rapport à emmanuel macron
qu'elle et vous faire à ce que ça va
toujours être du cas par cas
c'est quand on souhaite la réussite de
son pays et il n'ya au parti socialiste
que des militantes et des militants qui
souhaitent la réussite du du pays et de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens eh bien on se pose
sérieusement les questions quand on est
un parlementaire
on ne se contente pas de slogan on
examine en amendes
on vote pour ou parfois en votre contre
nous à lui-même de nous abstenir
mais on ne réduit pas de manière d'inr
un débat du passé
2pour contre de majorité d'opposition
tout ça c'est la politique d'hier ou
d'avant-hier
nous ce qu'on veut c'est ouvrir des
champs de la réflexion de l'imagination
des solutions pour les français
dernière question faut-il refonder le
parti socialiste refonder sa direction
vous parliez de najat vallaud belkacem
parce que ça
une personne qui doit compter dans la
direction de ce parti à l'avenir il ya
incontestablement une nouvelle
génération qui a émergé qui a prouvé en
responsabilité ce qu'elle était capable
de faire
je pense à najat vallaud belkacem je
pense à matthias fekl mais je pense au
dc à d'autres membres du gouvernement de
cette génération et qui doivent avec de
grands débuts locales comme la maire de
paris comme la maire de rennes ii ou
donnant prendre leurs responsabilités et
conduire justement cette nouvelle
génération vers des lendemains heureux
pour les français puisque nous ce que
nous voulons c'est vraiment résoudre les
problèmes tels qu'ils se posent à nos
concitoyens et pas de manière
simplificatrice mais dans la durée donc
nous portons un autre modèle de
développement une autre matière de
manière aussi d'animer la démocratie nos
concitoyens ils ont aussi demandé à
s'exprimer à participer et donc c'est à
ça que nous devons nous atteler
maintenant
merci beaucoup sont des deux masters
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors
que l'on attend d'un instant à l'autre
l'allocution de jean christophe
cambadélis qui va justement parler de
cette grande plateforme commune du parti
socialiste pour les législatives du mois
de juin merci beaucoup
tam a effectivement dans cette
plateforme il ya cette question aussi de
manuel valls on sait que l'ancien
premier ministre ce matin a annoncé son
intention son désir de rejoindre la
majorité présidentielle qu'est ce que ça
dit de l'état du parti socialiste
lui-même le considère comme mort dennis
baranger je sais pas s'il est mort ou
pas le socialisme comme courants
idéologiques il m'aura pas la question
c'est celle de son périmètre et de ses
capacités opérationnelles
il est pris entre d'un côté france
insoumise
de l'autre des centristes du
gouvernement monsieur gérard collomb
c'est un socialiste une certaine sorte
mes proches des centristes
il ya vraiment une question ce point de
vue là il se dit dans l'entourage d'un
marché de monsieur maintenant que ça
n'arrangerait pas tant que ça monsieur
macron d'avoir une majorité absolue
parce qu'il aura été très échaudé par
l'épisode des frondeurs que quand on a
une grande majorité on peut avoir des
frondeurs on peut en avoir de plusieurs
sortes désormais monsieur valls il a
subi les frondeurs il a tenté contre le
49-3 ça n'a pas protégé c'est la même ça
a même été le début de la fin pour lui
maintenant il essaye de ceux de se
rapprocher de monsieur maintenant je
vais pas porter de jugement sur les
stratégies politiques des uns les autres
c'est pas bon c'est pas mon métier je
pense qu'au fond on voit maintenant
l'effet induit de tout ce qui s'est
passé sous quinquennat de monsieur
hollande des primaires et du problème
qu'ont les partis politiques parce que
pour en revenir à ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure je n'arrive pas à voir comment
on aura un seul parti républicain d'un
côté et une seule rue de solférino de
l'autre elle est trop grande pour pour
tous ces gens là il y aura peut-être la
vieille maison au sens de léon blum ya
peut-être quelques personnes comme
cazenave qui garderont le parti mais
vois pas comment on n'échappera une
recomposition des parties nature sur
manuel valls effectivement cette
stratégie en interne chez en marche
qu'est ce qu'on pense d'eux manuel valls
aujourd'hui on a entendu ce matin
carrément même un tir de barrage en
disant on va leur poussée on aura un
candidat face à lui il faut qu'il
démissionne du parti socialiste au parti
socialiste on dit qu'il faut pas qu'ils
avaient la double étiquette
au parti socialiste comme chez en marche
finalement la rejeter et manuel valls en
marche pourquoi est ce qu'ils font ça il
ya deux choses la tête la première c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu peut-être
transparent pour nous et qu'on ne voit
un petit peu regardé il est peut-être
trop tôt de dire aujourd'hui oui manuel
valls tu peux venir avec nous il a fait
toute sa campagne sur le côté et droites
et gauches pas d'accord d'appareil etc
il ne peut pas dès aujourd'hui prendre
quelqu'un comme manuel valls qui incarne
un peu l'ancienne politique et dire à
nous rejoindre tu peux travailler avec
donc on est obligé un petit peu de faire
cette façade mètres un mur finalement
aujourd'hui mais il ya déjà eu des
portes entrouvertes qui ont été établies
aujourd'hui par notamment des proches
emmanuel macron je pense ou député
christophe castaner qui a parlé qui a
dit que oui il y avait des possibilités
et puis il ya surtout un homme
aujourd'hui qui fait un petit peu le le
go between pour envoyer un terme entre
et manuel valls emmanuel macron c'est
françois bayrou et françois bayrou il a
une expérience là l'expérience de du
soutien à françois hollande n'a jamais
été remercié pour cela il a même été
plutôt contrarié dans ses objectifs
d'être député il y a cinq ans il n'a pas
été aidé par la gauche à l'époque et par
le parti socialiste notamment et par
françois hollande qui lui ont mis
quelqu'un en face à lui et françois
bayrou dit très fortement en interne qu
il doit peut-être quand même réfléchir à
travailler avec manuel valls qui
pourrait très bien lui servir dans les
un ou deux ans qui viennent pour élargir
justement ce socle de cette majorité
donc vous voyez que en interne ans quand
il ya des grandes discussions dans la
république en marche avant de continuer
cette analyse
ces législatives ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement le troisième tour de
la présidentielle on retourne voir sa
verrière au geiq qui est devant le siège
des républicains a rue de vaugirard à
paris on sait aussi bien que la question
du ralliement potentiel à emmanuel
macron divise aussi chez les nerfs
savait rien absolument delphine alors
officiellement le menu l'objet de ce
bureau politique aujourd'hui c'est la
validation officielle du programme des
républicains pour les législatives et
bien sûr dans toutes les têtes il y à la
recomposition la décomposition des
républicains un arctique est de plus en
plus scindé entre les légitimistes
autour du chef de file françois bas rhin
baroin et tous ceux et bien qui se
laisseraient séduire par la tentation
macro tout oppose d'ailleurs d'écouter à
ce propos luc chatel c'était il ya
quelques instants
le procès de moscou n'a jamais été ma
fille âgés parmi les exclus mais en même
temps
et moi je crois plutôt à la démarche
collective aux démarches individuelles
la démarche collective c'est de se dire
on l'est derrière nos candidats aux
législatives
on les soutient on fait en sorte que les
français votent pour nos candidats et
c'est les français qui doivent décider
moi je crois que la clarification la
recomposition c'est aux français de
décider
voilà pas d'anathème un pas de procès de
moscou pourtant certains ont déjà
franchi le rubicon ou s'apprêtent à le
faire je pense bien sûr bruno le maire
alors pour le moment face à cette
tentation macro les digues tiennent
c'est en tout cas ce que nous disent ici
la majorité des ténors du parti mme la
question d'affinités le film c'est bien
sûr pour combien de temps merci beaucoup
savaient rien on continue avec vous nous
4s avec cette question voit que
finalement 48 heures après son élection
emmanuel macron qui voulait on peut
renverser la table bien en finir avec ce
qu'il a appelé la vieille politique le
système des partis traditionnels
il est rattrapé un finalement par la
logique institutionnelle de la 5e on
voit qu'il est obligé bien de
transformer son mouvement marchon un
véritable parti et se retrouvent
confrontés aux difficultés il ya les
deux y avait effectivement un fort
élément de perturbations quand même très
très important rarement une élection
présidentielle a perturbé à ce point les
grands partis au système ans de deux
parties a donc d'abord un élément de
persuasion considérable l'imaginons
quand même c'est bruno le maire manuel
valls est à dire des personnalités de
premier plan de leurs familles
politiques qui disent finalement oui je
me sent à l'étroit peut-être ou
peut-être que il ya une opportunité de
réaliser un autre projet politique donc
c'est quand même assez considérable mais
en même temps c'est vrai que le système
a une incroyable capacité à faire
rentrer dans le rang ceux qui veulent en
sortir et notamment obligeant à emmanuel
macron il va être obligé de transformer
en marche en un parti hier on a eu la
nomination d'une nouvelle responsable de
en marche qui déjà nous dit quelque
chose sur peut-être le choix du premier
ministre parce que j'imagine
difficilement que le nouveau responsable
dans marche et le premier ministre
viennent du même bord politique
donc on voit là aussi que de tout un jeu
de contraintes commence à se mettre en
place
et puis à un moment donné effectivement
il devra gouverner avec le système en
place et le système de parti il ne
pourra pas tout faire
par ordonnance il ne pas utiliser le
49-3 que très peu puisqu'il réforme de
l'utilisation du 49 3 d'eau qui à un
moment donné où la rencontre entre son
agenda de programme présidentiel et le
parlement va être absolument cruciales
il ne pourra pas se permettre lui qui
constamment dit je veux une démocratie
revitaliser je veux un parlement qui est
davantage restaurer dans sa fonction
je veut réactiver le dialogue social
aussi un il le dit beaucoup dans son
dans son livre-programme révolution il
ya beaucoup de passage widi faut un
dialogue social ressources et renouveler
c'est relativement contradictoires avec
l'idée d'un président gouvernants d'un
président qui qui gouverne pas en
donnant sur des enjeux majeurs donc
effectivement le système va l'obliger à
un moment donné à composer avec les
contraintes de ce système
rapidement tout à fait d'accord en
résumé monsieur valls il a un avantage
c'est qu'il est un président de la 5ème
et la 3ème de la quatrième il a des
pouvoirs que ces manoeuvres n'avaient
pas je me confonds excusez moi et
deuxièmement il a un autre avantage
c'est qu'il ya un front national fort
dans le pays
et puis une france a soumis ce forte
dans le pays donc de toutes façons les
parlementaires banques ont intérêt à
travailler avec lui bien merci dany
marange et merci beaucoup bruno coppens
merci à vous amical n'avait sa mission
concerne ou rejoint sur ce plateau
dans un instant l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir michel va s'enliser
on a beaucoup de questions à lui poser
en ce soir richard ferrand secrétaire
générale de la république en marche
exactement d'abord envie de l'interroger
sur le dossier valls qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent au fond est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement lui accorder une
investiture puisqu'il la réclame alors
ensuite on l'interrogera bien sûr on
rappelle que richard ferrand est
vraiment le bras droit emmanuel macron
comme secrétaire général de remarcher
maintenant de le république en marche on
va lui demander mais évidemment
et quelles sont les mesures prises
actuellement pour essayer de décrocher
une majorité absolue avec quel premier
ministre à matignon va lui demander
ensuite quelles sont les premières
réformes annoncées dès cet été pour
répondre à la crise sociale et puis on
l'interrogera enfin avec michaël szames
est présent ici sur ce plateau sur la
présidence macro quel type de président
c'est ce qu'ils nous préparent on a déjà
un petit signe avec évidemment la la la
cérémonie la marche vers le panthéon du
louvre c'était dimanche soir merci
beaucoup à michel l'épreuve de vérité
c'est donc à suivre en direct sur notre
antenne à partir de 18h30 en attendant
retour sur les principales déclarations
politiques de la journée je ne suis pas
un nombre jusqu'à ce je veux la réussite
et les manuels m'attends donc comme
j'invite d'ailleurs tous les députés
sortants les les progressistes ce qu'ils
ont appelé à voter pour emmanuel macron
avant le premier tour ce qu'ils
souhaitaient sa victoire moi je serai
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
et je souhaite m'inscrire et je souhaite
m'inscrire parce que vous m'avez demandé
une réponse claire je souhaite
m'inscrire dans ce mouvement qui est le
sien la république en marche que nous
allons analyser cette proposition nous
allons vérifier s'il s'est inscrit en
marche si il a déposé sa candidature ou
non la règle s'applique à tous y compris
pour monsieur valls et nous avons déjà
arrêté d'ailleurs sur la circonscription
de cheval une candidate
il n'a pas déposé sa candidature je ne
crois pas ça veut dire qu'il ne sera pas
candidat en marche uni réplique en mars
ça veut dire que si vous déposez pas
votre voiture vous ne pouvez pas être
investis par en marche mais là c'est
trop tard ce que c'est je dis vous
donnerai les noms
écoutez lui reste 24 heures est-ce que
c'est pas un tout petit peu humiliant
quand même pour l'ancien premier
ministre
on a l'impression de demander à gérard
depardieu de passer un casting quoi moi
je sais pas sur la profession artistique
qu'on considère que du moment qu'on vous
prend vous paye et tout va bien non moi
je trouve que les privilèges peuvent
être derrière nous et qu'il faut
appliquer à tous à commencer par nous
cette exigence ces mêmes manuels qui
devrait la porter lui-même ses terres ne
pas vouloir avoir un privilège du fait
de son passé mais revendiquées justement
d'avoir la même méthode
la même démarche que n'importe qui qui
habite à evry où qu'ils habitent à
forcalquier ou à barcelonnette ce parti
socialiste et est mort il est derrière
nous pas son histoire et ses valeurs vie
doit se dépasser alors qu'il jouait il
doit par exemple se ranger derrière
souhaitons qu'il devrait être beaucoup
plus clair que cela
si certains veulent partir ou se
singulariser qu'ils le fassent et nous
laisse travailler avant sa carte au ps
le label heures marche c'est possible
non ça c'est impossible
voilà c'est très simple voilà c'est il
faut faire ça très calmement les très
gentiment la campagne que nous allons
mener nous du côté des républicains
c'est la clarté à tous les étages chez
nous d'abord ceux qui choisissent
emmanuel macron étant un pays libre le
font naturellement et ils seront en
marche
ils ne seront plus les réserves ni ses
normes entre emmanuelle ma croix bien
des égards est ambigu il a gagné sur une
forme d'ambiguïté sur son projet sur
ceux avec qui il va gouverner là on voit
bien aussi que il essayait de faire des
petits débauchage que c'est pas clair il
veut détruire les républicains ils
veulent être répartie ou et détruire le
père le dj ça marche et ça c'est fait
mais nous nous détruira pas moi je ne
sais pas ce que c'est que ma ligne
moi je sais que je suis fidèle à marine
le pen
je sais que c'est celle aussi qui nous a
permis d'atteindre 11 millions de voix
je sais que c'est celle qui nous a
permis d'être au second tour l'élection
présidentielle c'est celle qui nous a
permis on sait pas que c'est maman qui
peut être l'incarnation du front
national en 2022 par exemple donc marine
mal du tout je sais qu'on va essayer de
faire monter les scénarios comme ça je
crois que c'est l'état d'esprit de
personnes
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de m'avoir suivi tout de suite
l'épreuve de vérité qui reçoit ce soir
richard ferrand secrétaire générale de
la république en marche bonne soirée à
demain
[Musique]
non